[Music]
this is a syringe full of water I've
closed off this end so it can escape and
no matter how hard I
push nothing really
happens I can't compress it even if I
put this inside an industrial hydraulic
press a machine that can push down with
thousands of tons of force the volume
would only decrease by about 1% but what
if it was squeezed even harder what if
this water was subjected to the extreme
pressures in the Earth's core or inside
the
Sun what would happen to
it the answer is something really
bizarre something physicists are just
starting to understand in many ways this
is really a new field we just don't
fully know the rules yet it's an
entirely new regime of matter to try and
wrap our heads around these extreme
pressures and the way they warp physics
as we know it let's go on a journey
straight
[Music]
down
we'll start our trip up here on the
surface at atmospheric pressure how much
pressure is that exactly how does it
compare to say the pressure of my phone
on my palm well the phone's weight about
2 Newtons is spread out over about 100
square cm that's how pressure is
measured a force distributed over an
area the pressure of the atmosphere the
hundreds of miles of air above me pull P
down by Earth's gravity is 500 times
stronger that's like the pressure my
phone would exert on my palm if Dwayne
The Rock Johnson was balancing on top of
it but because the air is free to flow
around it's also pushing up with the
same pressure every foam siiz patch of
my body is getting pressed inward by the
equivalent of The Rock's weight of
course all the structures and fluids
within my body are pressing back and I'm
so used to this equilibrium that I don't
even notice before we leave these
familiar conditions I'm going to grab a
few things to take with us a g of
hydrogen a g of sodium and a kilo of
water we know exactly how these
substances behave on Earth's surface but
what happens when we start to
squeeze just 10 m of seawat adds another
whole atmosphere worth of
pressure 27 floors down we pass the
unassisted diving record and just a
little deeper we hit 10 atmospheres
now we're going deeper than the deepest
scuba dive there's a blob fish they look
like depressed Jello-O on the surface
but down here the pressure keeps them
trim 1 kilometer down we reach 100
atmospheres the kinds of pressures we
got with that giant hydraulic
press sperm whales can dive this deep
and their hinged rib cages fold inward
so the bones won't snap here the Titan
submersible was
crushed and here is the destination they
never
[Music]
reached somehow we're still passing fish
and now we've reached the bottom of the
Mariana Trench and 1,000 atmospheres
we're now up to the pressure of a phone
with a herd of elephants balanced on
top let's check in on the samples we
brought our balloon of hydrogen gas has
shrunk down to the size of a big marble
but both our solid sodium and liquid
water haven't changed much they're just
barely compressed why is that well the
molecules of hydrogen had plenty of
space between them room to shrink but
the sodium and water were already
tightly packed even the pressure down
here can overcome the electrostatic
repulsion between molecules it's nowhere
near strong enough but let's keep going
every meter of rock piles on the
pressure nearly three times faster than
water the temperature is rising too as
we leave the crust we hit 10,000
atmospheres in the mantle temperatures
shoot past 1,000° and some of the rock
starts to melt this is where many
diamonds form carbon is squeezed into a
tight Crystal as we go deeper into
100,000 atmospheres of pressure the rock
is compressed further forced back into
its solid form our sodium meanwhile has
melted and our bubble of hydrogen is
liquid too compressed into a little
clear globule the water is also changing
it's getting squashed so much it's
forced to become a solid but not the
hexagonal Crystal we get on the surface
instead it's a tighter cubic lattice
scientists have found this variation of
ice ice 7 trapped inside
diamonds as we get close to Earth's core
we pass 1 million atmospheres that's the
equivalent of an oil tanker balanced on
a
phone this is the threshold we're now
leaving the world that physicists fully
understand this is where the external
forces are about the same and starting
to overwhelm the internal forces
crushing pressure is starting to
overcome the electromagnetic forces
holding water molecules apart and
maintaining their shape the behavior
that comes out of being in these extreme
conditions is pretty bizarre how do you
study matter under conditions that
normally only exist deep inside the
earth that was the point of creating the
center for uh matter at Atomic pressures
we're going to be doing all the
fundamental physics to be able to
understand matter under these really
different kinds of conditions cmap is
headquartered at the University of
Rochester and they've got a tool that
helps them create extreme pressures the
enormous Omega EP laser it fills this
giant
room this is the facility schedule
scientists from around the world queue
up for months just for a chance to blast
a tiny sample of matter with a laser
beam and how do you feel in the run up
to this unbelievably nervous uh you've
spent a year of planning and Crossing
teas and dotting eyes just to get to
this Point The Shot director gets on the
intercom and he goes 5 4 3 2
1 shot 3 9
607 is now complete that was it during
that Split Second million atmosphere
pressures were momentarily created in
the Next Room the same pressures that
exist deep within earth how does a beam
of light do that let's go through it
again just way slower
two
one the laser beam is born in these
machines down in the basement and it's
directed through a maze of lenses and
devices that shape and monitor it
bouncing through these massive tubes
it's infused with more power until it's
as wide as this opening about 45 cm
across then it races towards the target
chamber which is hidden behind this
tangle of
equipment this is a visual
representation of the Target chamber and
the target is right at the center of it
those are really like a pinpoint on the
tip of a pen just absurdly small the
target is a tiny inedible sandwich with
a sample of whatever substance the
researchers are interested in in the
middle the laser light is focused down
to hit this first layer which explodes
into a superheated ionized gas and that
plasma blows off of the surface like a
rocket that creates this buildup of
pressure that forms a shock wave and
that shock wave really quickly travels
through the material the last layer acts
as a window allowing the passage of
electromagnetic Rays generated during
the experiment and then surrounding it
you have these spaces to put different
cameras and other tools that we use to
measure the various things that we're
interested in if you look through this
port hole you can see a couple of these
sensors getting moved into
place in 2017 researchers put a tiny bit
of ice seven sandwich between two
diamonds in the Target chamber as the
shock wave passed through it pressure in
the ice spiked above 2 million
atmospheres and its atoms rearranged
oxygens formed a tight lattice while
hydrogens were free to diffuse through
it it was Ice 18 four times denser than
normal ice and able to conduct
electricity almost as well as a metal
for a few billions of a second the laser
had recreated conditions inside Earth
speaking of let's get back to our
journey as our starts to turn into ice8
our glob of sodium is undergoing its own
transformation under these pressures
scientists have seen it turn
transparent now what could account for
this well metals like sodium are shiny
because they have a bunch of free
flowing electrons that can absorb and
then retransmit light which we see as a
reflection what happens when you apply
pressure to it is you're squeezing the
electrons away from their atoms and into
these localized Pockets drapped like
that the electrons can't interact with
light and so it just passes
through we've reached the center of the
Earth but that's not the end because we
can continue into pressures found inside
larger
planets tens of thousands of kilometers
below Jupiter's surface physicists think
hydrogen will go through another change
becoming a shiny conductor of
electricity it's thought that a lot of
Jupiter is made up of this metallic
hydrogen we think of hyd enrgy densing
materials as completely inverting the
periodic table so your Metals become
transparent and your transparent
materials become metals and all these
gases become solids and the universe
holds higher pressures still the center
of Jupiter sees over 10 million
atmospheres just about the highest
pressure that the Omega laser can create
and now we're diving into the sun where
pressures rise over a 100 billion
atmospheres the island of Manhattan
balanced on a foam
we've seen extreme pressures
overwhelming the forces that keep
molecules apart but here within the sun
they can overcome the very glue that
holds atoms together here individual
hydrogen nuclei can be fused to form
helium a process that releases
energy this is nuclear fusion the
ultimate source of all energy in our
solar system the reaction at the center
of every twinkling star if we could
somehow recreate this process on Earth
and keep it going
we would have a near Limitless source of
clean sheep power and researchers around
the world are using giant lasers
including Omega to study this
[Music]
possibility this is all a relatively new
frontier of physics scientists still
have so many questions about the rules
about how different elements and
Substances Act and interact under
different conditions and how that might
influence the evolution of planets and
their ability to Foster life they'll
keep chipping away at those those
unknowns one split-second experiment at
a
time squeeze me tight get together about
the pressure feel so wrong but it Feel
So
Right break me down then you make me
hold you want a Di and take your time
and keep on trying cuz I'm just another
[Music]
cold I'm just go
now